before i tell this story i just want to
say i love colombia i love medellin i
love the city i love the country i love
the people i love
wow
oh this [ __ ] again
one thing
do talk about oh i tell you what
happened in colombia um
i can only imagine gringo okay the
culture i love the music
i love the food i love everything about
it i could live here it's a great
great country i have nothing bad to say
about colombia
now here's my story
on saturday night i went out with a
friend who i met here who's from new
york
we were wandering around kind of like
the nightlife area of this neighborhood
why [ __ ]
why
we were wandering around looking like a
whole cartel meal
what are you snack a whole snack a whole
cartel three-course meal oh look at here
johnny what is this this is nice what
are you doing bro let's find out what
happened and we came to a club it was me
him and his friend
so we go into this club and they're
playing great salsa music
i can already tell by the way he had
salsa but he probably doesn't speak any
spanish no let's go get some tacos
let's go get some tacos papa let's go
get some tacos
giveaways it's salsa okay
we decided to go
upstairs
now upstairs was more like a rooftop bar
with reggaeton
reggaeton reggaeton uh a mojito
no medellin is the capital of wreckage
music so if you're here you have to
learn to like reggaeton before i came to
medellin i didn't like regulator now i
like regular i can dance the regulator
it's great i i like it no problem
he's talking about it i've never seen a
25 year old boomer in my life
he talks like i've never really liked
reggaeton but i'm here now and i've
learned to like it and i can dance to it
so i like he really talks like he's
talking about his co-worker jared all
right i don't like black guys but jared
he's a cool dude
one two three five six oh all right i
messed up on the back step sorry sorry
maria
that laugh
so we go upstairs and we're dancing and
uh we're drinking and we're having fun
and we're laughing and we meet this guy
and these two colombian girls
how many more videos i got robbed in
colombia do you think we need to make
[ __ ]
this is a trap
they looked like they were having a
great time we all started having a great
time together we were talking we were
laughing
sharing stories dancing
really just enjoying our saturday night
yeah
so we got to know each other
uh two o'clock
of course the music stopped and the bar
shut down
everybody to the exit every game goes i
got a girl go to the other exit and get
robbed okay papa's wait for them outside
to empty their pockets but y'all we're
not getting to know each other they were
just sizing you up how easy is this
gonna be that's it
so
the guy from great britain said
i don't want to stop having fun
uh
it's still early um you know five
o'clock six o'clock is late on a
saturday night two o'clock's not that
late so let's go back to
his apartment that's what he said his
apartment and let's keep dancing let's
keep listening to music let's keep
drinking no problem i said okay let's go
i just want to bet there was some sexual
innuendos involved with those ladies
ain't nobody trying to go back to the
crib and dance with two other dudes who
says who
so these two girls from columbia
and this guy and me go back to his
apartment
we start playing bachata music and saw
some music and we're dancing in the
apartment
listen
you know what maybe it's because i grew
up ugly okay maybe it's because of that
i'm just suspicious of women who come
onto me fast or are very down a girl
want to do a one night stay with me from
the club don't get me wrong i have done
in the past but i've always been
suspicious if they're two down i didn't
have to work for it i'm too ugly for
that [ __ ] there's no way that a seven
or eight out of ten just trying to come
back to my place with with me you
understand what i'm saying i agree right
a thousand right
so i'm like who's sent because women
have tried they have tried to come home
fast and i'm like who sent you you
trying to you trying to pull something
right and i think that's why i've never
had to deal with getting robbed or
getting drugged or any of this nonsense
so that people do this all the time i'm
too suspicious so for this man to just
be like let's go back to
i could never
now the woman i just met especially not
with a local no especially not with the
local from there disappearing from the
struggle this is a prank i got that this
is this is ptsd from my childhood thank
god where every girl that came onto me
was like i think you're cute really no
you're disgusting and you know what you
know that like you like it was a it was
a prank so i became
yo no no no no who sent you this video
is brought to you by manscape.com a lot
of you guys asked me what my skin care
routine is simple i drink water i
hydrate and exfoliate and i wash my
booty if you don't know what to use to
wash your booty
i got the thing for you
man's cake got this wonderful body wash
this is body wash i say booty wash it's
wonderful it smells nice
and when after that you wash that you
probably want to trim it
trim your booty to trim your booty
we have the lawnmower 4.0 you could use
it underwater there's a guard for you
not to check your balls you know because
you don't want to chip them you know
what i mean you want them nice and clean
lawnmower submersible
uh
and that's pretty much it and you finish
it off with a wonderful man's cape
cologne don't forget the smell
we are a fan of their performing package
kit which is the world's first
all-in-one men's room and kit just go to
manscape.com use promo code abba and
preach 20 and get 20 off yeah i'm going
preach 20. and we're drinking
we have beers
and then
one of the girls offers me a whiskey and
a coca-cola
the next thing i remember
is waking up at 10 o'clock the next
morning
my cell phone i had two cell phones one
columbian number and one american number
my cell phones were gone
my credit card that i had on me was gone
and my cash was gone
what else was missing was
the girls the girls were gone okay they
were professional thieves
they weren't professional thieves
that you were a professional sucker okay
that's what happens
there were so many red flags in this
whole story it's like at some point and
look when alcohol becomes involved it
really does impair people's judgment but
i have to ask you go to a country where
i assume you don't speak the language
maybe he does but i assume he doesn't
okay
you go to a country that you're not the
most familiar with
which already has this is not like this
happened
in
downtown london in brampton okay yeah
okay it didn't happen in the same
[ __ ] branch okay it happened in a
country where this is common
and you at no point is like brother if
you can't make those kind of decisions
why are you drinking in these countries
i'm just saying
i've never been dominion
no
how did you not know yeah
how
the woman a woman runs up on me she's
saying papi papi all this
no
it's us
how you running up on me in the street
looking all interested i'm at a club
chilling these girls just coming on
super strong
that's us
what are you really here for because i
ain't that [ __ ] so you must be here for
my money i ain't that guy
come on man
if you come to medellin if you come to
columbia be careful
be careful
these girls were professional thieves
they drugged us with i guess with the
whiskey and the coke that's why they
don't tell you to not take tricks from
strangers
why why do you think
this [ __ ] is just this
[ __ ] got cardi b
i had to find my iphone app so i looked
at the map to find my iphone
so i'm thinking okay i'm telling the
police officers let's go to this
neighborhood because i i know where my
cell phones are they say no no we have
to do the we have to do this process we
have to check the video cameras i say
okay i take the guy from the uk i think
the british guy i said let's go to this
neighborhood
we go to the neighborhood
we're in the middle of nowhere we're
we're
just following my ipad which was gonna
die tracking yeah find my phone this is
so unbelievably stupid i don't know what
to tell you what if these people that
you're following are linked to a bigger
crime group and you're going in there as
two [ __ ] gringos about to run into a
crime den
and the police was like oh no we're not
doing this why do you think they were
not doing it it's not stupid they're
from there hey hey hey eduardo
see gracias you know you feel this karon
you feel this no i'm not going to get
your phone no those two girls that
followed you they came with a guy what
do you think of this [ __ ] you don't
you think they're just doing this free
willy-nilly no a lot of them get pimped
they get pimped into doing this stuff
and you know what pimps do they
traditionally run with
other criminals uh it was at three
percent i i had some address trying to
find my cell phone uh i wrote down the
address eventually and i was asking
everybody in the town where is this
address do you know these two girls
have you seen
these two girls have you seen my phones
can i get my phone back
nobody knew
uh
we told them the story they felt bad for
us
we left empty-handed we didn't find the
credit card or the cell phone or
anything like that basically
my story here is saying if you come to
columbia
be careful
if you if you rent an airbnb or an
apartment or or if you have a hotel and
you decide to meet some friends or some
locals or anything and you bring them
back with you
they have to leave their
identification number
at reception or with a guard these two
girls didn't do that i why i don't know
i think they just
they know the process they're they were
they were really professional thieves
let me tell you or they just got people
you just pay the person at the reception
at a good 20 40 bucks and you slip right
through money will oil all the wheels
let me tell you listen a bunch of red
flags already terrible for this man to
run up in that neighborhood he's lucky
he's still alive you know what's the
worst part is
yo i don't even understand how i got
that [ __ ] that quick listen i'm not even
that smart
i'm not but that [ __ ] is coming i'm not
a genius
that's just common [ __ ] sense
bruh
man brother you bugging you buggers
listen uh anybody who's watching this
traveling is fine you can go to these
countries and you can be safe you just
have to be intelligent about how you
move
don't go to bars you probably don't know
where places you don't know and get
really drunk one two do not accept
drinks from strangers whether it's here
or over there okay unless you see it
being made in front of you
don't ever if you're even at a bar here
people get roofied all the time
do not accept people's drinks
and three be careful about how much you
carry or how much you take with you when
you go out two phones not the strongest
thing i got two
[ __ ] why you got your american head
bro store that [ __ ] away have a burner
you know what i mean have a bucket
have a bucket phone you mean a bucket
phone a bucket phone something you take
out when you go out like a phone you
were fine with losing i know well i got
a bugger phone right here exactly that
looks like a bucket dude yeah that
should crack down stains and [ __ ] it's
cracked up and [ __ ] but you know what if
you know you're going out now you
getting wasted be smart about
as far as ids don't carry your passport
with you i know stupid people who don't
bring other alternate id's they lose
their passport they're stranded
costing them thousands of bucks trying
to get [ __ ] sorted don't do that
bring it bring a photocopy of your
pocket and if you're bringing a girl
home in a country like that make sure
you vet her don't be rolling but listen
people are gambling
a [ __ ]
well you could actually go out with them
a few times
that's one way because that's a lot of
time investment for some that may not
happen yeah two
maybe don't bring them back to your
place rent a small room somewhere else
and smash them there
you don't have to bring them to your
home yeah and also if you meet her at
the club
social media searches don't hurt if i
met a girl online you best believe i'm
asking for a socials make sure
everything's kosher that she's legal
that there's no nonsense there's a lot
of things people can do to protect
themselves and also
watch how people approach you that's
going to be the best biggest indication
they don't have that much time noise
they trying to get their money in and
out quick quick quick
they coming on super strong
that should raise your alarm bells
someone comes up to you like hey man i
have a great way for you to make some
money
pyramid scheme anybody
acm
america right so anyways just be smart
about it when you guys travel don't be
this guy herbalife because you know
fortunately for him it only resulted in
a few phones being lost it could end up
way worse yep you can end the way it
works so we've already posted this
you went you went out to get his phone
way worse that [ __ ] is done bro rough
you can't be doing that but anyways let
us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear from